proposer des moyens de transport
modernes et écologiques
voilà la mission que s'est donnée le
syndicat des transports ile-de-france
mobilité samedi 13 mars valérie pécresse
a annoncé l'achat de 1000 nouveaux bus
propres pour la région d'ici 2022 2023
pour pouvoir recharger ces bus en
électrique ou en biométhane pendant la
nuit
40 de dépôt devrait être transformée
d'ici 2022
nous nous sommes mis résolument dans
l'électrique pur j'allais dire les
villes les grandes villes les dessertes
aux courtes distances et dans le gaz le
gnv le gaz naturel de ville pour les
grandes distances ce gaz il peut être
propre ou pas plus ou moins propre mais
il est zéro carbone zéro émission autre
innovation présentée samedi au dépôt de
bus transdev de conflans sainte honorine
un nouveau système de rétrovision il
devrait permettre aux chauffeurs de bus
d'avoir une meilleure vision latérale et
d'éviter les phénomènes d'angle mans en
plus des rétroviseurs physique on ajoute
des caméras qui permettent de compléter
la vision que va avoir le chauffeur de
son environnement et de lui de nous de
permettre d'abord à la fois pour les
manoeuvres d'être plus précis mais
également ça lui permet d'avoir une
vision là sur les parties latérales du
bus qui sont souvent cachés et d'éviter
les accidents
d'ici 2025 plus aucun bus diesel ne
devraient être en circulation dans la
région ile de france
objectif adapter à terme la totalité des
centres avec de l'électricité ou du
biométhane